今日の 今日は直接本題に入って順番に説明していきたいと思っているんです
アビダンマっていうのはとにかく心の働きを分析して理解してもらおうということの勉強ですが
その場合もやっぱり形而上学的に分析するんじゃなくて
我々が経験できる体験
認識という立場から見ているんですね
この初期仏教とは他の仏教との違うところはそういうところで
初期仏教では経験できないものについては語らないんですね
他の宗教やら他の仏教の違うところは
全く経験もできない 何もありともわからないものについてよく喋る
そういう知らないものを喋ることは宗教だとというふうに一般的にみんな思っているんですね
その世の中にある固定概念に引き摺られて
わけもわからないものを喋ることは宗教だと
ですから そこら辺 仏教というのは釈迦の教えは何か宗教ではないんじゃないかなというふうに
ヨーロッパの学者たちが言うこともあるんですね
やっぱりそれはまさにその考え方が間違っているわけじゃなくて
自分たちが知っている固定概念の宗教と仏教
釈迦尊の言葉を聞くと
すごく違うということが見えてくるんです
釈迦尊が体験できるもの
人間に知ること可能なものしかお話はしない
宗教なんていきなり創造論から神のことやら地獄のことやら天国のことや
そういう話が出てきたりとか
あるいは仏教だったらそういう全然わけのわからないいろんな概念いっぱいありまして
仏性やら発心やら三身論やらいろんなものが出てきて
それは本当にそんなものあるかどうかわからない
それで仏教でまたある有名な認識なんじゃなくて
唯識論という教えがありまして
すべては心だけですよと言ってますけどね
全部心だけですと言ったって
我々にとっては客観的な社会は見えるし
人は見えるし 私は今見ている人は私の心の中で自分勝手に作っている幻覚だよということはなかなかちょっと理解しにくいというか
ことにもなっちゃうし
それからそちらの中でもやっぱりそれはそれでいいんですけど
この阿頼耶識という潜在意識という絶対意識不可能な意識があるんだとと言ってるんですね
だから意識不可能な意識があるということはありえないということになりますからね
知ることは全くできないものもありますよ
だからあってなくてもどうでもいいんですからね
我々の知ることはできないんだから
だから我々の問題っていうのは知ることから生まれるんですね
知らなきゃそこに問題ないんですね
例えば今土星に何かあるかと
火災 火山爆発しているんですかとかね
どうでもいいことなんです
私たちにとっては知ることは不可能だから
関係ないんですね ですから
人間の問題っていうのは知ることから生まれるのであって
ですから その知ることの範囲の中で心の働きを分析するということは
仏教の立場なんですね
それ以上は真理があるかないかというのは
ただの頭の回転だけなんですね
例えば簡単な理屈で言うなれば
ここには建物があるんだと
そうするとこの建物を中心にして
じゃあ他の建物もありますかと聞けるんですね
じゃあありますよと言っちゃえば
じゃあこの建物と他の建物と以外
別な建物はありますか？と言えばありますか？ないんです
そうするとないと答えなくちゃいけないんですね
じゃあこの建物と他の建物と以外
別のものはありますか？と言えば
答えはあるっていう答えになっちゃうんですね
そういうふうにこののは頭の回転であって
じゃあこう言えば言えば他
この建物と他の建物と
それから別なものと それ以外何かありますか？と言えばどうですかね
答えは そこで答えはないんですね
あるかないか分かりませんだから
簡単にはないとは言えるんですね
論理上ではそんなものないんだと
この建物 他の建物 それからそれ以外のものありましてね
他のものもありますから
それを乗り越えて他のものがあります
でもそれはないんです
そういうふうな質問がセットがありまして
それはテーラワーダ仏教の始まりのいわれなんです
今言ったことは スリランカにテーラワーダ仏教
インドから紹介したところで
一番初めにマヒンダ長老が王様に会うんですね
山の中で 森の中で 狩りに行ったところで
あったところで マヒンダ長老が別に仏教とかアドとか話じゃなくて
このやりとりやってたんですね
この木は何ですかと あ
これはマンゴーの木ですよと
で こういう国々ではリンゴの木は有名であるのと同時に
我々にとってはマンゴーの木なんです
で これはマンゴーの木ですと
じゃあこのマンゴーの木以外
他の木 マンゴーの木ありますかね
ありますよ いっぱいありますよと
じゃあそのこのマンゴーの木
そのマンゴーの木除いて他の木がありますけど
いっぱいありますよ あっちこっち
その木とこのマンゴーの木
そのマンゴーの木と乗せて他の何か木があります
そんなことないんだとさっさと答えたんですね
それで この人はちゃんとした物事を考えられる
自分で物事を考える人だ
だから仏教は理解できるんだなと思う
インド朝を決めたというふうに
我々の大師というスリランカ人の歴史を書いている大きな本があります
そこにそれを記録しているんですね
仏教の由来についてこういうふうな対話があったと
ですから 私は冗談で言っているんじゃなくて
一応昔の人々の考え方と今の人々の考え方と全然進歩してないんですね
進歩しているところがどんどんどんどん考え方は客観退化しているような感じもするんですね
で とにかくこの仏教の心の働きっていうのは
この認識という立場から認識できるというところで
心は認識する 働きは心であって
その分析をしてくれるのはアビダルの教えなんですね
で その中でも やっぱりいきなり心の説明に入ると
まあちょっと難しくなるというか
まあ難しいわけじゃなくて
まあきちんとずっと続けて聞いてないと
あっちこっち抜けちゃったらもう繋がりがなくなっちゃいますからね
決して難しいことじゃないんですね
そういうことで 今日は認識心の問題を置いておいて
物質のことを説明しようと勝手に決めたんです
まず物質論から始まりましょうと
で 私がそう決めた理由は
一つは分かりやすい 番目の理由は
この人間というのは いくら心や心や精神やと言っても
結局考えているのは体のことなんですね
物質のことなんですね
それ以上何も考えてないんですね
で 体があって心があるという状態なんですね
例えばもう怒ってはいけませんと
落ち着かなくちゃいけないとか
なんでそう思ってるんですかと
まあ落ち込んだらいけませんと
暗い考え方を持ってはいけないと
なんでそう思いますと
やっぱり体があって それ落ち込んだら体がいろいろひどい目に遭ったりするし
怒りやら嫉妬やらそういうものあると
自分が社会で人間として生きている場合はいろいろ苦しい目に出会うんですね
だから結局よくよく見ると体のためなんですね
そこで極普通の人間の道徳であろうとも
修行であろうとも 座禅であろうとも
何にしたっても ちょっと見ると結局体のためにやってるものなんですね
ですから 普通の人は運動して
美味しいものを食べて
健康的な食べ物を食べて
いろんな体ばかりいじっていると
そういう人と それ以上瞑想したり
いろんなことをやったりしていると
あんまり差がないんです
どっちでも体のことしか考えてない
この精神的なことを追っている人々の違うところは
自分が騙されていることに気づいてない
それだけなんです ですから
よりバカと言えばよりバカで
より欲が深いと言えばより欲が深いなんですね
ただそれだけのことなんですね
いわゆる食べて遊んで音楽を聴いて楽しむよりは
より優れている楽しみがないんですかと
その楽しみっていう概念がやっぱり体から生まれてくるもので
結局同じところでぐるぐる回っているんですね
そういうことで 我々は正直にこの
そこら辺は認めなくちゃいけないんですね
この代表者のパティパダーに入れましたけど
この法句経の 63番目の偈文でこの
自分が愚かであることをちゃんと知ってる人が人がそれによって賢者になるんだと
自分が愚かであるながらも
自分が賢者だと思ってる思い込んでる人はそうすると本物の愚か者だと
ですから我々のこの本当の状態に気づいたら
そこで知恵が生まれてくるんです
とにかく仏教で言ってる幸福っていうのは
決して体中心にしているものではなくて
体に依存するものでもなく
心に依存するものでもないんですね
ただ 体と心のためにやるものではないんです
でもそこでずっとみんなヴィパッサナー瞑想したっても
求めているのは何か体が良くなってくれるんではないかと
健康的になってくれるんではなくて
より幸福になんとかならないんではないかとかね
そこら辺ではね すごいこの相反する性格であって
その中で何とも言えない安らぎというか
何も求めない心で落ち着いた心
消えた心で 火が燃えてる
火が消えた心が生まれるんであって
それはなんかすごい快楽感とかね
というふうなものではないと思った方がいいんです
ですから やっぱりすべてを否定する
否定するんじゃなくて
捨て去る心が生まれなくちゃいけない
体に基づいて幸福を味わうではなくて
こんなくだらない体はどうでもいいやと
そういうふうな気持ちにならなくちゃいけない
心をなんとかもう知恵を発達してもらって
すごい抜群の才能 もう抜群の人になろうということではなくて
こんな瞬間瞬間変化する心はとんでもないゴミだと思って思うように心を入れ替えてもらわないと
本当のヴィパッサナーの世界っていうのは出てこないかもしれません
とにかく人間っていうのは体中心に考えていて
それで我々の知識はどういうものかというと
全ての知識も物質中心なんですね
物質の分析 物質のありとあらゆる角度の理解
地理学にしたっても同じことで
じゃあ歴史は何ですよって言れば
いろんな時代においていろんな現象がどう変化しましたかという教えは歴史であって
科学の世界もそういうことであって
それしか他の勉強ないんでしょ
世の中で それから芸術
美術の世界で それもただの物質の世界だから
音楽やら絵やら何したっても
踊りやら ですからもう我々のこの膨大な知識というものは
ただの物質のいろんな角度からの分析であって
でもその誰一人も完全にこれを把握して分析してみようとはしてないんですね
自分を決めた角度で物事を見る
芸術家が自分の目で物事を見る
ただそれだけ 事実はどうでもいいんです
その人にとっては ただ自分の世界でそのものを見る
音楽家はありとあらゆる音だけ聞いていて
それも音をありのまま聞くんじゃなくて
音楽の耳で聞いている
例えばうるさい犬が吠えているんだと
うるさくてうるさくて
音楽家はそれ聞いて この音はこうこうやって使えるんじゃないかなと
自分の作品にはと思ってしまうだけのことで
ですから物理学も同じことで
力学も同じことで そういう角度で見てるだけで
全体的にものは見えることはない
そこで物事は側面で見るということは
決して知恵とは言えないんですね
例えばこの本を見て この本の長さだけ見て十センチですよと言ったっても
本の説明にはならないんですね
あるいは色だけ見て青いですよと
それは青いものですと言ったっても
本の説明にしたことにならないんですね
ですから ただある角度で物事を言ったっても
そのものを説明したことには決してならないんです
まあそういうことで じゃあ仏教で物質はどう見ていますかと
物質論のところに入ります
何章でしたっけ あれは
このテキストの百七十五ページ
で いきなりこの六章に入りましたけど
六章っていうのはやっぱり心のところ終わったところなんですけどね
普通の順番でいえば 心の知識はきちんと積み込んだところで
識の分析に入りますけど
ここで我々は識から始まります
で 二番目マーティカというものがございまして
それは日本語訳ありますから読んでみてください
サムッデッサ・ヴィバガ・チェ・サムッタナ・カラプ・ト・パヴァッティカマ・パヴァッティカマ・トーチェティ・パンチャ・ダータット・サンガホという
この五つのカテゴリーに分けて説明しますと
で あの きちんとしても学問的に書いてますから
これからは物質そのものを説明しますと
その場合も五つの項目の中で説明しますと
で 一番目はサムッデッサですけど
これは日本語の言葉何でしたっけ？え？説教って私は全然知らない言葉ですけど
説教って言えばわかりますか？わかりなければ大丈夫です
まあ英語で言えばイニューメレーション
まあこれこれこれこれこれこれぐらい物質はありますよと
一応リストですね 物質というのはリストですね
説教 このリスト終わったところで
あの 分別 いろんな分け方に分けてみると
それ終わったら その いかに物質が生まれるかという
この物質の因果法則ですね
それから物質はどうやって固まりますかと
で その物質のこの固まりということは
この組み合わせなんですね
どうやって組み合わせて現象が生まれますかという組み合わせ論と
あの 正気の純情と書いてますけど
このパヴァッティカマ
物質はこのどういうふうに変化していきますかという
まあこのあり方ですね
その五つのカテゴリーに説明します
で またこのきちんとテキストに従っていくと
あの また文化的な差がありますから
この なかなかわからないかもしれません
ということは このテキストはこの学生さんに暗記するために書いてるもので
決してアビダルマの内容を説明してる本じゃないんです
ただ名前ばっかし書いて
それを暗記しろと 暗記してから
もうアビダルマを教えてあげますと
アビダルマの本は別にあるんです
それかなり量なんですね
それ勉強読めないんですね
言葉知らないと いわゆる最初用語ですね
用語の意味を 定義だけ教えてあげる
その時わからなくてもいいんだと
一応覚えておきなさいと
ですから暗記させちゃうんです
暗記してしまえば ものすごく簡単にもう
あの 勉強できるし そこで注釈書やアビダルマのテキストなんかは
やっぱり前提としてこういう基本的な知識がある
あるという立場で書いてるんですね
そこがないと思っちゃったら
本なんかは書けなくなっちゃうんです
まあそういうことだから
この あの これをまあ暗記するために
この伝統的にアビダルマ勉強する人々ということを考えて
ずいぶん昔書いた本ですから
まあ我々のは全くその通りに勉強してうまく理解できるっていうことはないんですね
まあですから まあ適当に私はまあ説明のやり方は変えたりはします
じゃあアビダルマのまず
あの 分別というよりは
この何て言います イニューメレーション
まあ一つ一つ別々にこのリストの紹介
これから入ります  [咳]まず
あの あの物質は二つに分けます
まず二つに分けます  Upādāyā rūpa
こっちにも Rūpa と入れてもいいし
なくても大丈夫です この二つはマハーブータルーパ
ウパーダールーパという二つなんですね
で ウパーダーという Upādāyā rūpa ですね
もし あの 伝統的にこのタイやらミャンマーのお坊さんたちからいろいろ話を聞くならば
あるいはそういうお坊さんたちに書かれた本なんかを読むならば
いろいろちょっとパーリ語でちょっと問題が起すかもしれません
で そこで別にそこまで問題は起こらないかもしれません
だけど発音の差がありまして
このたまにこのタイとミャンマーで書いてる本ではこの文字が変わったりするんですね
パーリ語で それはその方々は発音する次第に書いてある
これはもうインターナショナルの
いわゆる国際的に学者の世界で認めているという基本的な標準の書き方なんです
それからこの あの パーリ語をものすごく厳密に使う人々は
これはこの格変化させちゃうんですね
で 例えばマハーブータっていうのは複数で
あのニュートラルジェンダーって何でしたっけ？中性名詞ですね
ですからマハーブータニと書くか
マハーブータルーパニと書くんですね
ですから ルーパの代わりにルーパニと書くんです
それはもう格変化してして後なんですね
この場合もウパーダーエルーパニとなっちゃうんです
で それ別に覚えなくてもいいんです
なぜならば この格変化したところで
もう文章の一部なんですね
文章の中の一部なんですね
ですから 名詞としてちょっと使いにくいんです
ですから ただ名詞の元の形で書くのは我々の普通の書き方なんです
格変化しないで 例えば普通の
例えば 私は日本語を勉強した時でも
自分というのは日本語で何と言いますかと
それは私 私ですと教えてくれなかった
私 ただそれだけ 文章での場合は
私はというふうに 私はと私を私がと色々なっちゃうんですね
私のとかね そこでどこかでアイというのは私のとか私はと書いちゃったら
ちょっとおかしくなっちゃうんですね
知ってる人にとっては私という
まあ何も変化してない元の形で書いた方がまあいいとこう言うと分かりませんだけど
まあそれも一つの方法ですね
ですから たまにこのパーリ語で覚えようとなさってる方々は
このいろんなテキスト読むとちょっとした差が生まれるんです
それは気にしないでくださいと
学者の間で国際的に認めている形で一応紹介していきます
そこでまず 物質は二つのカテゴリーに入れておきます
一つはマハーブータ もう一つはウパーダーヤ・ブータ
そのマハーブータの日本語の名前はだい？大衆と書いてまして
まあちょっと気に入らないな
日本語の言葉なんですけど
このブータという言葉
すごくいい言葉なの ブータっていうのは簡単にこのあるというぐらいの意味なんですね
あると言ったっても このすごくニュートラル的に中世的なあるなんですね
いるというよりは ですから
何かあるものという意味なんですね
それはあるもののマハーっていうのはもうよく知ってますからね
マハーというのは大という大きいという意味ですからね
ですからこの あるいわゆる存在の中で一番大きく基本的なものという意味なんですね
ですから なかなかふさわしい日本語の言葉がないかもしれません
まあ代数でもいいし で
マハーブータ じゃあこれから説明すると分かります
で 物質の世界で一番基本的な
とても基本的な物質はマハーブータというんですね
物質は分析して分析して見ていると
もう最終的に見つかるもの
元素みたいに まあそれ以上は分析はできない
その物質にマハーブータというんです
そのマハーブータが基本なんですね
ですから 現代の言葉で言えば
まあ基本的な物質とということになっちゃうんですね
で じゃあウパーダーヤ・ルーパって何ですかと
これは絵師と何とは書いてありますけど
で この基本的なものがあるんだからありますと
だから本当は基本的な物質さえあればいいんです
でもこれ基本的な物質が出てくる
それなんかまたそれからまた二次的にまた他の物質も出てきて
それ全部まとめて我々知っている物質の世界が生まれてくるんですね
ですから これに依存しているんですね
マハーブータに依存してウパーダーヤ・ルーパが生まれるんですね
マハーブータがなければウパーダーヤ・ルーパがないんです
まあ紅茶がありますよと言ったら
当然紅茶あることありますけど
やっぱり水がなければ紅茶は存在しないんですね
で その場合も水の中で紅茶という何か物質が当然ありますけど
まあそれですが いい例えにならないんですね
うーん あの化学変化の中では分かりやすいと思いますよ
例えば水素と あの 何でしたっけ？水素と
酸素ですか で あって それは別々なもので
働きも違うし その二つが一緒になったところで水が生まれるんですね
水には別に水素の特色もないし
酸素の特色もない その働きもしてくれないし
違うことをやってくるんですね
そういう風に でも違う水は違うことは確かなんですけど
やっぱり水素と 酸素 なかなか日本語のあれ忘れちゃいます
とにかくこの水素と酸素で二つなんですね
でも水素の働きも の働きもしておりない
そういうふうに このマハーブータの中でいろいろ組み合わせの中から
こういうパーダールーパという依存している物質も生まれるということなんです
じゃあ次にマハーブータって何ですかと
この マハーブータということは四つなんですね
この四つだけすごい丁寧に勉強しておけば
そうすると全部終わります
マハーブータは四つしかないんです
カタマン パタヴィ ダートゥ アポー ダートゥ テージョー ダートゥ ワーヨー ダートゥ ブータ ルーパ― ナーマ
で じゃあこの四つの色
この物質といっても 仏教用語で色というんですね
色と字を書いて 色でいいかどうかわかりませんだけど
物質という言葉でいいかどうかちょっとわかりませんだけどね
まあどっちでもあまりいい言葉じゃないしね
パーリ語でルーパというのも
それまたあんまり定義は良くないんですね
この物質には パーリ語の言葉っていうのはルーパなんですが
このルーパっていうのは定義は良くない
で ルッパティーティ ルーパンという定義で変化するんだと
一定していないんだと
だからルーパと言うんだと
いろんな他の原因によってずっと変化しているものについてルーパと言いますよと言って
それでもあまりすべては変化するんですからね
心も変化するものですから
心もルーパですかとも聞きたくなりますけど
それでも寒いとか暑いとかそういうもので変化するんだと
物質は でも寒い時は心も変化してしまっちゃいますけどね
暑い時はまた心も変化してしまっちゃいますけどね
ですから 定義としてはそんなにいい定義ではないんです
一応理解としてはわかりやすく
まあすぐ変化するものだ
だから物質と言うんだと
その定義したっても 仏教の違うところ見えるんですね
普通だったら物質といえば
やっぱり一応本来にあるもの
ただ科学の世界でも やっぱり我々知ってるこういうものはよりは
やっぱり元素として基本的な物質はあるんだと
そのものは別に変化はなくて
あるものであって それから我々作るものは変化するんですね
例えばご飯は食べたら変化するんだけど
それはカーボンやら酸素やら他の成分はそのまんまなんですね
私はご飯食べたんだからといって
そこは全部違うものに変えるから
違うものになるわけじゃなくて
そのご飯だったら 米だったらね
カーボン 窒素とか それいくつかしか入ってないんだけど
水素とかね そういうものはまた分解して他の状態に戻る
でも水素は？水素は水素のまんまで
酸素は酸素のまんまで
炭素は炭素のまんまでというふうに何となく思っているような感じがありまして
そこで元素はあるというところで
じゃあ物質でもそういう考え方なんですけど
仏教ではやっぱりそれを取ってないんですね
物質やらルーパやらと言うんだけど
やっぱり変化するんだと
そのものもこのこれは基本的なものだと言ってるんだけど
それを見ると それはもう強烈に変化していくんだと
だからその強烈に変化していくという意味でルーパと言うんですよという定義がございます
じゃあマハーブータの場合は四つは
何でしたっけ？地水火
このマハーブータはこのだいたいよく聞いてる言葉で地水火風なんですね
その言葉っていうのは
やっぱりインドでは極一般的なある言葉の一部なんですね
ヒンドゥー教になると
それにまた他のもの入っちゃうんですね
地水火風 空も入っちゃうんですね
それからそれもなんとかもう一つ入っちゃうんですね
魂も まあいろんなもの入りますけどね
仏教は全部余計なものは捨てちゃって
認識できないものは捨てちゃって
地水火風という言葉だけ借りてるんですね
言葉は借りたんだけど
考え方は借りたわけじゃないんです
決して だからみんな同じ言葉で喋ってるんだから
それはまあどうしようもないんです
例えば我々は英語で仏教を喋る場合は
キリスト教の言葉を全部使ってるんです
他の言葉ないんだから
だからでキリスト教の教えを真似て
それにしたがって喋ってるっていうことにはならないんです
言葉はもうどうせ使わなくちゃいけない
だから仏教で地水火風があるんだから
いきなりこの単純な人っていうのは
まあやっぱりもう同じことですね
ヒンドゥー教でもありますね
素晴らしいですねとか
まあ頭に ちょっと勉強しろと言いたいんだけど
ちょっと言葉似てただけでもうすぐケツの無い論文書いちゃうんですね
言葉似てるのは当たり前ですけど
言葉じゃなくてその何の意味で使ってるかというのはね
まあディノテーションですからね
それはもう言葉に二つ意味がありますからね
それ使わなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあ あの そこでこの地水火風を聞いた途端
地はまあ土であって まあ水は水の字であって
火は火であって 風は風なんですね
原文でも同じ意味の字なんです
日本語だからちょっとおかしいっていうことではなくて
原文にしたっても地は何でしたっけ？パトリ
アーポー ワーヨー で パトリ
アーポー テージョ ワーヨーという四つなんですね
まあそれ原文ではパトリは土であって
アーポーは水であって
テージョは火であって
ワーヨーは風なんですね
で まあこれはパーリ語で
サンスクリット語っていうのは
ヒンドゥー教の世界では
ヒンドゥー哲学の本ではこのプリティヴィー
アパス テジャスとワーヨというふうな言葉で出てくるんです
それサンスクリット語になるとまた変えてしまっちゃうんですね
パーリ語っていうのは一つのダイレクトだから
一つの方言だから 方言
ですから そういうふうに変化するんです
で まず説明する前に ものすごい我々何も知識ない
ただのもう原始的なもう社会で生きてる
原始的な大変失礼な言葉ですけど
別にこのただ農業だけして
まあそれで何か食べて
それでまあ寝て 朝起きてまた畑で仕事をして
それぐらいの生活しているぐらいのレベルで
別に文字も書けませんしね
もう余計な天文学やら星占いとか
そんなことも勉強しないしというふうな人で
のレベルで考えたとしても構いませんということなんです
まず言いたいのは いわゆる地は土で考えたってもいいんです
水は水で 火は火で 風は風で
ですから 私の 私は人間としてどうやって出来上がってますか？というのは
これは土で 土があって
水があって もう体を作るんだから日があって
それから風が体の中を通って
それで体ができているんだとすごい単純に理解したっても
それはぴったし合ってるんです
決して嘘じゃないんです
ですから この私たちは
現代人がものすごいきめ細かく
難しく 物事を考えたくて考えたくてしょうがないんだけど
それちょっとあの なんか頭がかゆいでしょうかね
わかりませんだけど 別にそんなに難しくてもう考えなくても
昔の人々のように まあ土と水と火と風と
それをまとめてもう私たちはできているんだと
そういうふうに理解したっても
決して真理からは離れたことにならない
そこが不思議なところなんです
まあですから まああの大体なんでそういうことを言ったんですかというと
大体この仏教の注釈読むと
そういう説明が出てくるんです
特にアブダルマの注釈というのはすごい後後のものだから
このテキストも随分後で書かれた本で
そのテキストに注釈書があります
それはもうかなり後で書かれたものですから
まあまあ そんなに厳密に解釈というよりは
すごい俗っぽい解釈とかあります
その中で皆さん普通の日本語でありますから
読んでみてください いろいろなんかおかしいこととかいろいろあるかもしれません
それはまあそれなりにいいんじゃないかなと私は思います
じゃあこれからどうしよう
じゃあ一つ一つ説明いたします
なぜならば 一つ一つ説明するのが一番別ですから
じゃあパテリー パテリーというのは結局仏教の世界でまあ土だと思ってもいいと思ってはいるんだけど
この厳密な解釈だけはそんなに簡単に理解できるようにしておいてなかったんです
きちんと定義しているんですね
このパテリーというのは
このものの硬さ 重さ 作るエネルギーとして
働きとして取ってるんです
いわゆる私は自分なりに考えて質量を作る働きなんですね
質量といえば まあどんなものにもそれがありますからね
重さとかねというものは
だからこの この なんでこのこれも理解してほしい
これ認識からいくんですね
ここに私がいて ものを見る
ものを見るといろんなものを見ます
見えますけど そのどんなものにもある質量というものがありまして
重さがありまして 硬さがありまして
何か何かそういうもののあるようなことは体験できる
それは昔も今も同じことで
今の科学者も人間だから
人間の目で耳で鼻で聞いてやってることだから
誰であろうがこの質量は認識していて
ですから この定義としては
このものの硬さはただ楽かな働きとして硬いと
というエネルギーは体に入る
そのエネルギーを考えてパテリーと呼ぶんです
ですから土ではないんですね
いわゆる土そのものにもパテリーの働きがありまして
それから水が取ってみたら水も硬いでしょう
水にも硬さがありますね
ですから 水にもパテリーがありまして
じゃあ風はどうですかと
風も硬いんです 硬さが持ってます
重さが持ってます 質量あります
ですから 風にも硬さがあり
パテリーがありまして
風の中にも じゃあ火はどうですかと
火にも重さも硬さもあるんです
だから火に手を触れると
ああ熱い熱いと感じる前に体に触れてわかるでしょ
ああ これは炎だと 触れたらすぐ分かりますから
先にわかるのは硬さなんです
熱いと感じるためにはほんのちょっと時間がかかるんですから
ですから 燃えてる火にしても重さがあります
硬さがあります 空気にもあります
風にもあります そうでないと
どうやって風が来て家を倒す
倒したり 木を倒したりするんですかね
木を倒そうと思ったら私たちにもできませんだけど
風にできますからね その硬さが働いて
それを倒してしまっちゃうんです
ですから 全ての現象の中で
全ての物質の中にこういう硬さがあるんです
なければもう歩かないかは私たちには言えなくなっちゃうんですね
そこでそれもある物質という意味ではなくて
エネルギーであって なぜならばこの体で感じるものだから体に伝わってくるんですね
伝わって流れていくんですね
例えばこのチョークを触ると
このチョークを持ってるこの硬さというエネルギーを私は手で知ってるんですね
指で 指にその その流れていくんですね
だからこれはあると知ってるし
これ触っても全然硬さが感じない場合
私は全然これはあることわからなくなっちゃうんです
ですから この基本的な物質ではなくて
基本的な働き エネルギー
エネルギーの波動 それを見て
あの硬さと言う それを理解しやすく私は言うのは
この素粒子のように考えましょうと
この電子 原子はまあ分解して
それいろいろいったところで
まあ最終的には素粒子というものがあるんだと
物質 物質の世界で言ってるんですね
そこで素粒子っていうのはmatterの物質の一番元のものなんです
その素粒子自体は一応matterかparticleか何ものかとなかなかわからないんですね
素粒子そのものは それは波動であって波であるとも言いながら
ある立場から見れば波動であって波であると
ある立場から見れば それはparticleであると
物質でmatterであるとも言ったりする
で なんか曖昧でつかみにくくて
でもあることは確かなんですね
素粒子っていうのは ですから
研究 実験する場合は 素粒子の実験する場合は
これを物質として確かめようと思って
そういう実験装置を作れば
物質として出てくる じゃあエネルギーとして見てみようと思っちゃったら
エネルギーとして出てくる
では一体全体何ですかと
なぜならば 例えばこのある素粒子がこうやってある一定の法則で流れていくんだと
そうすると ここで邪魔すれば
このはこうどこかに変化するか
また帰って戻るかということは
普通に物質の流れなんですね
でも素粒子一個の流れにここを邪魔すれば
大体ここで一つ流れて
ここで一つ流れて 枝分かれ流れになったりするんですね
そうすると 一個の素粒子が二つになったことになるんですね
なるんだけど また何のことなく一つになってしまっちゃうんです
だからそこら辺どう説明すればいいかとは
やっぱりもうわからないんですね
それからこの変化するのはものすごく不確定なんですね
物質的な決まってる変化ではなくて
自分なりのいろんな変化を起こしてるんですね
ですから この素粒子の例で考えた方が
あの わかり 一応 あの お釈迦様
仏教でおっしゃりたかった意味に近いんです
だからパテリっていうのは
このものの ものに 物質に硬さ作ってくれる
重さを作ってくれる 質量を作ってくれる
基本的なエネルギーの流れ
波動 波 なんです だから波動だから波だからどうせ一定してない
どうしても変化していってしまっている
それから二番目はアーポー
アーポーっていうのは水っていう字書いてるんですね
そこで あの アーポーの
これも素粒子なんですけど
その素粒子の働きはすごくわかりやすいんで
例えばこの小麦粉とか何とか持ってきたら
これバラバラなんですね
吹いちゃったら もう風でももう口ででも吹いちゃったら
あちこち飛んでいっちゃうんですね
それでこの小麦粉に我々は水いっぱい入れて
もう均等に水がどこにも伝わっていくように
それは練っておく そうするともう一つつなげてるんですね
離れませんね 普通小麦粉だったら
もうこうやってもうサラサラだと落ちてしまっちゃうし
口で吹いちゃってもすぐ飛んでいっちゃうし
お互いにつなげてないんです
水を入れてちゃんと練ってみたところで
もうきちんと一つの塊になっちゃうんです
その働きを考えてください
一個一個の小さな小麦粉の粒が
水がついたところでどうなったんです
お互いにつなげているんですね
逃げられないように それで塊が出て生まれちゃうんですね
そこでこの物質というものは
大体小麦粉みたいなもので
ベースにつながりがない働きなんです
いわゆるザーザーとエネルギーがありまして
それは重さあることはあるんだけど
全然つながりがないんだから全然わからない
例えば一キロの小麦粉を買ってきたら
それは一キロの重さあるでしょうね
じゃあ こんな一粒一粒の小麦粉を測ってみてください
どれぐらい重いかと 全然重さがないでしょうね
だからそれはもう顕微鏡でもとって見て
一つ一つ分けてもらわなきゃ分けられませんし
その一つ一個一個測ってみても
当然重さがあるんですね
まあ原子としても重さがありますからね
まあ問題ないんだけど
当然重さがあります その重さが全部まとめたところで一キロだとは言えますけどね
じゃあ一個はどれぐらいですかと言えば測れませんね
そういうふうにエネルギーはもうバラバラで
お互いに何にも繋がりがない場合は
もう存在としてはもうなかなかいられないんです
それで水というアーポーという元素の素粒子の働きがあります
そのアーポーという素粒子が
この この地という素粒子を一つ一つ一つ一つつなげていくんです
だから引っ張るんですね
引っ張ってしまっちゃう
お互いにつなげておく
逃げられないように引いておく
これ引っ張るエネルギーなんですね
で そこは難しくないんで
例えばこれは粉でできているのに固まりでいるでしょう
あるでしょうに で 違うエネルギー入れちゃえば
これはまた粉にすることはできますしね
私の体もそういうきめ細かい原子のような粉
粉でできてますけど やっぱりつなげてるんですね
こうやってね 捻ってもなかなか抜けないんですね
やっぱりきちんと なんで私の指でこうやって皮膚を取っても一部抜けてこないかというと
そこはアーポーの素粒子が働いていて
もう逃げないようにしているんです
つなげているんです だからつなげる力がアーポーである
で そこで四番目に行きます
ワージョ 四番目の素粒子
そこで例えばパタウィという素粒子があって
またパタウィという素粒子がありまして
またパタウィという素粒子があります
それはアーポーで アーポーという素粒子で引っ張っちゃうんだと
引っ張るとどうなるかというと
引っ張られて引っ張られて引っ張られて消えてしまうんですね
お互いに 例えば物は二つあるんだと
この二つのものはどんどんどんどん近寄って持ってくると
近寄ってどこまででもお互いに近寄ることができるならば
二つも一つになるしか方法ないんですね
そうするともう最終的にはもう二つあったんだけども
一つになってしまっちゃう
それはどこまでも考えると消えるはずなんです
お互いに引っ張られて引っ張られて引っ張られて
もう制限なく引っ張られてしまって
もう消えてしまった でも我々知っている見ている世界は急に消えたということはないんですね
今あったんだけど すぐ消えましたと
ということはないんですね
そこでこの和陽という働きは
この引っ張ってるエネルギーの反対で引き離す
あるエネルギーとこのエネルギー二つ考えるとお互いに引っ張らないように
こうやって両手を分けてるような感じで引き離すエネルギーを作ってるんですね
そこでどうなるかというと
例えばパテリーという物質がありまして
またパテリーという物質がありまして
そこにアポーという素粒子が出てくる
素粒子が出てきたら この二つのパテリーを一つに一つの場所に引っ張っていく
引っ張っていると その中に和陽という素粒子も働いてるんですね
和陽という素粒子は引っ張らないように引き離すを引き離しているんですね
そこでどこかで止まらなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば引くエネルギーは強い場合はどんどんどんどん小さくなる
引き離すエネルギーは強くなってくる
どんどん大きくなっていく
そこでちょうどいいところで止まる
もうそれ以上はくっつかなくなっちゃう
それ以上はくっつかない
そこで我々に目に見える物質は
時空関係の中でこの物質っていうのは生まれてくるんです
例えばこのチョークの中に和陽の素粒子だけ働いている場合はどうなるかというと
いきなりこれは粉々に爆発して出て行っちゃう
もう全然近寄ることはない
どこまでも逃げて逃げて逃げて永遠に逃げていくんですね
その働きはいつでも可能なんです
こちらの阿婆の働きを
もし誰かが取ってしまえば
いきなりこれも爆発して
もう永遠に逃げていくんです
だから 宇宙にあるこの素粒子っていっぱいあるでしょ
この星とかそういうものではなくて
宇宙空間の中で それはもう永遠にもう逃げるものは永遠に逃げていて
どこまでも でも物質にまだなってないんですから
もう今の我々の体を通って
もうずっともう大量の素粒子が出ていくんです
例えばニュートリノという素粒子がもう太陽から膨大な量が出ますよ
これは決して我々に掴むことはできないんです
この地面にそれぶつかったら
ずっと地球を通って外から出て行っちゃうんです
あまりにも小さくて ニュートリノから見れば
この地球なんかはもうものじゃないんです
穴だらけででっかい穴ばっかり
その中から何のことなく出て行っちゃう
ですから 僕らの体にも大量のニュートリノはぶつかります
一つもぶつからない 全部通っていっちゃうし
どこまでも逃げていく
ということになるんですね
ですから このそこで あ
これ三番目の定常って何ですかと
やっぱり定常っていうのは定常でいいんです
熱でいいんです でも熱という定義もありまして
またちょっとずつ違う定義もありますね
やっぱりエネルギーとエネルギーと
エネルギー一つ もう一つエネルギー一つになると何が生まれますか？って
やっぱりそこに熱が生まれちゃうんです
これなんかどうしようもないことで
おかしいことでね あれ不思議なんですね
例えば両手をこうやって引っ張るとエネルギーは生まれるんであって
全然冷たくはならないんですね
だから氷二つ持ってきて
一つにこうやって 何て言いますか
けすると熱が生まれてくるんであって
氷は溶けちゃうんですね
だからやっぱりエネルギーはもう熱は生むんですね
あれだから エネ あるいはエネルギーそのものに熱とも言う場合もありますけどね
そこで熱は何をするんですかね？熱はこの形を変えちゃうんですね
熱入ったらその構造を壊してしまっちゃうんです
壊すというよりは変化させちゃうんです
ですから この我々知ってる世界の現象の変化を起こす
そのままは置いておかない
という働きは 定常 熱なんですね
火なんですね そこで じゃあ地水火風を
まあ理解しましたと置いといて
で 地水火風をまとめたところで
人間に認識できる最初の物質の一番最初
一番基本的なものの生まれなんです
いわゆるユニット その四つは決して別々に存在はしない
いつでも一緒にいる 離れません
離れたら終わりですからね
間違ってでもアポナが消えちゃったら
もうもうバラバラでしょうに
風が風の元素を取っちゃったら
もうそこで消えちゃうでしょ
一緒になっちゃって だから収縮というんですが
収縮してものが消えるか
膨張して消えるかという
この宇宙の消え方二つあるんですね
今のうちは膨張過程であって
いつか消えちゃうんです
それでまた出来上がっちゃう
出来上がって吸収始めるんですね
そこでどんどんどんどんまた宇宙が現れてきて
またそれそれ収縮して
また消えてしまう という宇宙の法則があるんですね
それは遠い昔 仏教ではごく当たり前のことで
膨張の宇宙 膨張して止まってる宇宙とかね
あるいは吸収している宇宙と吸収を止まってる宇宙とかね
いろんな宇宙の概念がいっぱい入ってるんです
それは宇宙とも同じであって
我々知ってる小さな物質とたっても同じことなんですね
だからすごい物理学とは似ているような立場なんですね
宇宙を知ったっても同じことで
ちょっとした他の小さなものを勉強したっても全く同じことです
何も差がないんです で
あのまあ 科学的な知識があればもっと詳しく説明できると思いますけど
まあ私では全くの無知ですから
科学に対しては であの
じゃあ一応まあ簡単にこういうふうに理解しておきましょう
あの  世の中でいろいろ物質はいっぱいあることはあります
宇宙の中にもいろいろ物質はいっぱいあることはあります
その物質の基本的な 一番基本的な
一番小さな一個は地水火風という四つのエネルギーの働きによって成り立ちます
いわゆる一番小さなものには何かの質量
重さがあって その重さがまたあるもので繋げてあって
あるもので引き離してあって
また変化 お互いに変化しているという
ですから この電子一つ見ればよく分かりますね
電子というじゃなくて
原子アトム 原子一つ見ると
これはやっぱり分かりやすい基本的なユニットなんですね
でもそのアトム いろんな種類がありますね
元素は いろんな種類あるってのは
どれぐらい地が入ってて
どれぐらい風が入ってて
どれぐらいか入ってるぐらいの差なんですね
いわゆるあの ニュークリアス
アトムの真ん中の 核 核ですね
例えば核の重さで差が決めてるでしょ
それは核の中でどれものをいっぱい包み込んでる場合は重いし
ほんの少々しか物がない場合は
それは軽いし その軽いもの
重いか軽いかということによって
我々は百いくらかのこの元素があると考えているだけのことです
で その周りにまた引っ張られているものがありまして
引き離しているものがありまして
それまた落ち着いてないんですね
動いてるんですね エネルギーだから
止まったらそこで存在がなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから あの 原子一個
一個というものが見ても
そこはやっぱり動くものなんですね
ただの動くということだけで
物ではないんですね 物であるならば
それ見られるはずなんですね
残念ながら原子さえ見えませんね
原子顕微鏡でも なぜ見えないのは
それは見えるものではないんです
ただ あるエネルギーがそこでグルグルグルグルグルグル変化しているだけで
ですから いろんな工夫して
その原子のいろんな他の素粒子の放射ですか
もういろいろ出してみて
反応どうやって跳ね返ってくるかとかね
それを計算して それではこれぐらい大きいものがあるんだと計算するだけで
ですから この原子顕微鏡とか
いろんなもので この原子とか電子とか見ますけど
あれは直接見ることじゃなくて
計算して結果から作るものな
映像なんですね 物そのものは見えないんです
そこで計算して作った結果見ても
これはもういつでも落ち着きがなくて
動いて動いて動いてるんですね
すごい面白いんですね
この我々は金がいろんな
大体金ってのは見やすいものですけど
私もテレビで見たんだけど
この金の原子をね どんどんどんどんどんどん倍率を高く上げて上げて上げて
もうナノの世界で見え始めるんですね
綺麗に これもうテレビ画面で映しちゃうんですね
ブラウン管に それちゃんと丸く丸く丸く丸くあるんだけど
落ち着きないってことはものすごい
ちょっと人がちょっと
ちょっとしゃべったら
ちょっと音がしたら ブラウン管のあの絵が全部グチャグチャグチャグチャ変ななるから
我々はこの原子顕微鏡の中であって
空間 あの 何て言いますか
真空状態を作って いろいろ工夫して作っている
ほんの小さなサンプルなんですけど
あれでもちょっとここでしゃべると変化してしまっちゃう
僕らはもうちゃんと金の銀の塊持って首につけたりして
俺もこれはもうもう代々持てますよと思ってはいるんだけど
そんなことはないんです
ちょっとしゃべっただけでも
もうものすごく原子レベルでは変化してしまっちゃうんですね
だからそれすごく面白いといえば面白い世界なんですね
そこでこの 特に本当は私は説明しなかったんだけど
よく説明 理解してほしいのは
この阿婆 火の幻想なんですね
火の幻想っていうのは
地の幻想と水の幻想と風の幻想がまとめて
その三つを落ち着かせなくて
いろいろ変化させてしまっちゃう
その 火の元素 あるいは火の元素があるんだからこそ
物質はいろんな変化は可能なんです
それわからないと思いますけど
別に簡単です このこんなに難しいことを本当にこういう南アジアの仏教の党の人々は知ってますかと
ということ 知ってますからね
どうやって知ってもらう
例えば米があるでしょ
米に適度な水と熱を与えてみてください
どうなるんですか？ご飯になるんじゃないんですか？あるいは水をあげないで
米に火だけ熱だけ当ててみてください
黒い粒になっちゃいますから
あの変化可能なのは火だからなんです
それをごく普通の現象の世界でだって同じことなんです
で だからでしょ 我々は物を保存する場合
どうしますか どんなものもすごく保存したければ
火だけ入らないようにしちゃえば
だから冷蔵庫あるんじゃないんですか
まあ冷蔵庫の中にも火はありますけど
変化の極力火だけ入らないように気をつけると
そのものが変化は遅くなるんです
だから -40度で置いておけば
もう何だかんだもう そのまま動き止まりますからね
動き止まる場合は大体風の動きも止まっちゃうし
あの大体もうアップの動きもいくらか止まってしまっちゃう
だからこのバラの花なんかは粉にするのは難しいでしょ
40度ぐらいに冷やしてみれば
バラの粉は何のことなく作られますから
このフリーズドライシステムですか
そうするとただのバラの粉なんです
それから粉として働くんです
溶かして飲むこともできますよ
バラはいくら煎じてもね
溶けませんだから バラの花はそのままあるでしょ
それを冷やしたところですぐ粉になる
それだったらなんとなく普通のティースプーンで溶けたように
で飲めると だから我々知ってる世界でごく普通にあることなんです
その中で究極的な真理もあるんです
ただ人間がそれを見ようとしないだけ
科学者を見ようとしない
余計なことを考えてるだけ
ですから仏教の世界では
別に原子とかそんなものを発見する以前に
この素粒子の基本的なエネルギーを発見していたんですから
だから物理学にしたって
もうほとんどもうそれ以上進めないぐらい進んでるでしょ
それ以上科学発展なくなっちゃいますからね
昔やっていたんですから
やっぱりそうでしょうね
インドでは何千年も科学発展してない
そういうことで この ですが
我々実際に使っていることなんですね
物は保存したければ冷やしておく
早く変化してほしければ温めておく
パンなんか作りたい場合は
あれ小麦粉やらイーストやら全部ちゃんと適当にこれ混ぜておいて
暖かいところに置いとく
低速で置いてちゃったら全然もう膨らんでこない
で 冬になってくると植物はもう動かなくなって止まっちゃうし
春先になってくるとどんどん動いてくるんだから
細胞はもう活動し始めちゃうんだから
私の体も同じなんです
夏になってくるとどんどん活発に動くと
それで冬になってくると
どんどんどんどん機能が少なくなる
一番これは自然にふさわしく成功生活するのはクマですよ
もう冬眠しますからね
あれすごく正しいやり方なの
細胞動かないんだから
じゃあ休止してみましょうと
ほんのかすかな動きで
人間だけ冬は食べるは食べるは
もうそれでみんな 体の調子が悪くなる可能性ありますけど
やっぱり動きが鈍くなってくる
それぐらい行動を控えた方がいいし
昔の人間そんなもんでしょ
例えば日本にしたってお祭りはいつですかね
大体夏でしょうね あれは昔から冬はじーっとこうやっていて
なんとかちょっとだけ食べて
それで春になってくると
もう動いて いろいろもう農業だったり
いろんなことで作物をちゃんと取って
もうものすごく暖かいんですね
食べ物もいっぱいあるし
それ食べるわ それからもう動く
ですからやることがないんだから
お祭りでもやろうではないかと
歩いてお祭りをする そこで喧嘩祭りあるいはだんじり祭り
あるいは裸祭りある いろんなもう
で まあそれはそういうのは自然的にできていてあげるもんなんです
ものすごくバカバカらしいですけど
いまだにやってますからね
たまに人死んじゃうんです
このいろんな神社の祭りで
でもやりますから やっぱり自然的にそうなってしまっちゃうんです
まあ動く時は ですから
熱は一番存在の物質的な存在の
何て言いますか かなり役を果たしてるんです
変化の役目を で それをもうわからない
それでもわからないというならば
例えば原子の中でこの電子というエネルギーは周りに働いてるんですね
それを取り出そうと思うとすごいエネルギーが必要なんですね
そこで過去を過去の中に何か違うエネルギーを入れちゃったら
違う素粒子で鉄砲で撃つように撃っちゃっ-